as we approach the election we're
continuing our reality check on
president trump's immigration
policies in part two how those policies
are affecting
families seeking a better life here last
week we learned that the deported
parents of hundreds of migrant children
cannot be found after they were
separated at the border
average went to the border in texas
to see what it's like for those hoping
to enter the u.s
our ride-along with border patrol
brought us to this family of three
their story of despair shared by many
other families often worsens
long after reaching the border although
the trump administration's child
separation policy is no longer active
the aclu recently revealed
court-appointed lawyers
couldn't find the parents of 545
separated children it's a problem the
group justice in motion is trying
desperately to solve
we are the ones tasked with finding the
parents who have been deported
after their children were taken away
from them at the border executive
director kathleen karen works closely
with human rights attorneys on the
ground like dora milada
these parents want to be reunified the
question is how
can they get reunified but acting
homeland security secretary chad wolfe
argues the parents
made the decision to stay separated when
given the choice
the reunification efforts come as
another trump administration policy is
making it harder for those seeking
asylum
in 2019 the trump administration decided
that asylum seekers from other countries
must remain in mexico while waiting for
their cases to be heard
claiming the humanitarian approach will
help to end the exploitation of our
generous immigration laws
homeland security officials have said
the nearly 53 percent reduction in
apprehensions
can be partially attributed to that
decision but it also led to camps
like this one springing up just across
the border
with immigration courts closed due to
covet concerns
some refugees have waited here for more
than a year
my concern is the safety the families
are exposed to so many dangers
sister norman pimentel is working with
these asylum seekers across the border
are you frustrated with where we are as
a government as a country
all our policies are geared towards
simply to deter families to discourage
them
to totally disregard the humanity for
cbs this morning
medea vial in hidalgo texas